What up, welcome to coffee Ella.
Today we're covering part two of the Nigerian scammer. Today.
We confronted him and ask him why he did it with what's in his mind.
What's going on in Nigeria.
But before we go get into anything else before we talk about the $10 million
studio, which as you can see is coming together. Let me say,
I saw a disturbing figure on the internet.
This may be the worst thing I've ever seen. Check it out.
58% of you have not smashed like
and subscribed dude. How many times does Anaqua have to tell you?
Okay. Um, I'm off. Okay. So this October,
my goal for October is to get this number to 50%
subscribes need to come up. And if you're not subscribed, you need to leave.
So that's my big thing for October. Uh,
we can only write so much when he wrongs on the internet,
but this is definitely one of them. Now, anyways, without further ado,
let me just say.
Um, how's this audio sound by the way.
We fixed that, I know that was potato for awhile. It's getting better. It's not,
I'm not going to say it's perfect, but it's getting better.
The visuals are getting better.
The $10 million studio I told you guys just patience. Oh, there it goes.
It popped again. Patience. I got to not, sorry.
I got it up.
Uh.
Coming together slowly, but frankly I could use, um,
some of your help if you happen to have some digital 3d work and unreal engine
or anything like that for virtual sets, uh, I could really use you, frankly.
So if you're familiar, if you're a fan of the show,
if you're looking for a side project during Cove, um, I could really use it.
All right. That's it. Sorry to rant at you guys for a little bit.
I know a lot of you are going to be like ha video starts at two minutes. Uh, no,
everything I just said was very important. So enough of that,
don't say that ever again. But anyways,
let's talk about what we came here to talk about,
which is my confrontation with the scammer.
So at first things first I tried calling him and I'm going to go,
why didn't you call him? I tried, he immediately hung up on me.
And so I panicked and I was like, Oh crap, he's going to block this number.
Cause I only had one number for him. So I immediately kind of, uh,
played hardball. I said, look, you block me. I'm going to the authorities.
I'm going to SARS. The truth is I was bluffing.
I don't even know how to get a hold of, of SARS.
I wouldn't have gotten a hold of SARS anyway, playing hard ball,
playing with scammers. So I said, look, you, you go to go, go to block me.
I'm going to go to SARS. Bye. I said, I have screenshot.
This is after he hung up on me. He said, who's this? I said,
just an interested journalist. I dunno, am I a journalist? I don't know if I am.
We'll just say, Hey, what scam? So he plays dumb. I sent him some screenshots.
He plays dumb. No, that ain't me. What scam? That are no scam going on. Anyway,
liar. He establishes himself as a liar early on in this conversation.
Just want to say that. Okay. He's just playing dumb.
Are you talking about a Bitcoin scam or something? Finally, I get to the point.
I say you scam people with Instagram investing pages.
There's no getting out of it. I know everything it's too late. Oh,
I understand now. Ha. It didn't work, bro. People were smarter,
especially when it comes to Bitcoin, press X to doubt.
This is a part of the conversation. I almost skipped by it.
Cause frankly it's like kind of useless.
Cause he just denies making a lot of money.
Now in some ways we don't know if he's not telling the truth here.
Maybe he wasn't making money. On the other hand,
he lied to us at the beginning of the conversation.
And this is exactly what a scammer would say.
If they were afraid that you were going to go to the police or report them or
anything like that, of course he's going to go, Oh yeah, I I'm not,
I didn't make any money. I don't do it anymore. He says,
now all he does is he trades trades online,
which is stupid. As you guys know,
you're not going to make a lot of money doing that.
So he's probably still scamming. That's just my guess,
but I'm not going to try to confront him on this because frankly,
I don't think that's a productive conversation to have. Instead.
I try to turn it and make it about scams in Nigeria in general.
What do you thinks about the morality? Because my question is,
do you guys care that you're scamming people? So I'll, uh,
scroll down to that part of the conversation cause he just kind of denies it.
And so I go, how deep did these scams go? He's trying to say, Oh,
you should check out this trader. I don't care. And so he goes, honestly, bro,
I can't really say, but there are a lot of greedy people out there.
One thing I can assure you as a fact is that everyone you see on Bitcoin on
Instagram is a scammer.
Whether the person posted a photo or commented under that photo. Okay. True.
True. Honestly true. And so then finally he's like, okay,
I understand how wicked it is to ruin someone's life through scam. Okay.
So he's kind of confessing a little bit, you know, it's like,
I understand I'll wake. It is, but then you do it. Like what?
I mean, come on buddy. Why would you do it? If you know? Well that it's,
you're saying it's wicked. Okay. Then he says,
but why would someone invest with a stranger in the first place that promises
dubious returns, bro? I find it hard to give anyone money online.
Uh, yeah. You find it hard to get people in money online.
Maybe that's cause you're a scammer. So I said,
I wonder that myself many times probably because the people who do this are
expert schemers and know how to convince people with social Brown.
And I show him evidence of that, him doing that basically tricking people.
And I say stuff like this is how people get trapped.
They see the social proof and think it's legit.
That's how Ponzi schemes make money. Like of course this guy.
I mean, if you're in the industry,
like from my side of trying to bust these guys or you're a scammer, of course,
you're going to say, well,
you can't trust anyone online because this is the stuff you look at all.
But he's neglecting the fact that most people are not like scammers.
And you know, in the comments section of my last video,
I'm going to have to pull up a few examples of this.
But I had a bunch of comments basically saying that this guy,
all his excuses about why he had to do that,
they're just lies because we apparently have a bunch of people, uh,
in our comment section that are Nigerian, but they basically goes,
it's sad that a lot of people support them. You scammers in Nigeria,
they're called Yahoo boys.
A lot of Nigerians don't see anything wrong with it because they see it as they
are taking money from people that are rich.
So it's not bad or anything in some of them point out that even they're like a
parent currently from rich parts of the country,
or at least they're saying that they're saying they're upper middle class or
went to some really good schools because they have written English.
They've been wealthy and have been wealthy for a long time.
And so the psychology they use here is a,
just a justification method mechanism that they can only use with foreigners.
Nigerians would call BS on the reasoning. So yeah,
it's important to include that as we go forward with this because like he does,
he is the little bit slick here and he's trying to say, Oh yeah,
I totally understood. I didn't even make money with it.
I don't even do it anymore. I think a lot of, uh,
people in the comment section from blast video and this video are going to call
BS on that because I don't believe it. I don't think they believe it.
And basically, yeah. So for a long time here,
I'm not even gonna go through all of them.
I'm not even to give them the time of day on this because he's just basically
saying the whole time that I'm, I'm not making any money.
And then this is pretty funny. He goes,
can I refer you to the stock's chat room?
He's talking about the trader that he likes. He's like,
can I refer you so I can get a referral as if,
as if we're going to join. He's trying to scam me in,
in the conversation where I have the Friday gap. What is this guy doing?
And I was like, yeah, sure. Just to have a few more questions for you. First.
Number one, was it the morality that got you to stop stocks,
colleges and fair David Farris FX? Or was it the fact that he wasn't,
it wasn't working? Number two is everyone in Nigeria afraid of SARS?
I've read up on them. They almost seem like terrorists.
They just got some sketchy motivations. He laughs at that, I say what?
He goes stock's college, isn't a scam. David Farris. That's a total lie. Okay.
Again, this guy's lying.
He's been caught multiple times already in this conversation line.
But that also is alight stocks.
College talks about needing David Farris for the scam.
So of course he was scamming. He talks about scamming,
but he says David verse was because it was,
they take account of a different individual and it wasn't working out because
people knew it was kind of fishy to invest $500 and receive 20,000 in a month.
Again, we don't have any verification of that.
There's a saying that SARS are actually angry because they miss the opportunity
to scam in their days. So they catch young boys and collect money from them.
You did not hear this from me.
And the interesting thing is that I think there's some evidence for this of SARS
being very corrupt because multiple people contacted me about it.
And they say SARS, the division of the police, that tackle robbery.
But they found out that it makes no sense chasing robbers and risking their
lives.
They simply stop and search youngsters knowing they could make money easily.
This is because they can simply call a scammer and most people would believe.
And when they catch real scammers,
they simply collect as much funds as they can and release them back into the
wild. Basically in Nigeria,
you can apparently stop and search without a warrant or cause. So that's,
what's interesting is like, he's kind of right about SARS being a bit of a scam.
Uh, cause we've heard it from multiple people now. And he's saying like, look,
they shared amongst themselves,
the government doesn't pay them as much as they can make from young scammers or
rich people doing well in the country. Like they have a job to catch scammers.
Bail is their side hustle.
Which is insane. Um.
And then he goes, please, please leave stocks. College is out of this. There,
this is legit. People do that, bro. We've got them in DMS, scamming people.
What are you talking about again? Uh,
I think he was just covering for his buddy here and he goes,
that's why I mentioned greed.
There are people greedier than you can imagine that want to get rich quick.
They're greed leads them to loss of money, not the scammer. Okay.
Bravo for the biggest mental gymnastics in the world. Oh, it's not my fault.
They're a lot losing money. Yeah, it is your fault. So then he goes, man,
I'm trying to take time to go into details for you.
And I ain't even getting paid. Time is money. Yo
blessed me with funds, bro. Dude,
scam into the better end bro. I'm probably broker than you.
Like I don't know what you're talking about,
but then our scammer here actually starts to get insightful. He goes,
if you're looking for a business, you'll find a business.
If you're looking for a get rich, you'll find it.
The scam that is actually true.
There are victims who they get themselves in these situations because they are
actually actively looking for way to get rich quick and it just doesn't exist.
And he goes on. There's nothing that can be done. Even if it gets exposed.
He's talking about Nigerian scams.
People have been getting scammed since the 1970s check the history.
It didn't start overnight.
What needs to be reformed is the mindset of the youths.
We have kids in Nigeria who were thinking of scamming because of no money.
I saw a 16 year old boy or younger boy today with an iPhone 11 pro max.
I knew straight away that it was a result of a successful scams or fraud.
The music in the country promotes scams.
The government promotes scams indirectly to their actions.
So does the police and everyone else it'll make a good story,
but I'll introduce more youths into scams. If you choose to go with it.
Now I disagree with that. I think education is the key.
I think sunlight is the best disinfectant aside.
Totally disagree with him there. But I just follow up like,
can you elaborate on that idea that the government and music promote scams and
he says,
youths will figure out that scammers are really successful and we'll indulge in
it. They believe they can scam all their lives without consequence.
That's the mindset, bro.
I believe the only solution is the reformation of the African people.
The reason they scam is that because they don't know who they are amongst
themselves. Dude is anyone hearing like some, uh,
patriotic music backing here? There's a pretty good speech,
honestly, pretty good speech for a scammer.
Therefore it's safe to say that the government is scamming its citizens.
The youths have seen that and they don't want to be slaves underneath a greedy
government.
Therefore they decided to attack everyone and make money any way they can.
The youths are only reciprocating what's being done to them in their country.
Like it's not.
A bad line of reasoning, but it's also trying to absolve yourself.
It's clearly so self justifying and self mode motivated.
But I wanted to say, I mean, he has a point. He says so, uh, from within,
so without worldwide scams in Nigeria is a reflection of what's really going on
in the country in Nigeria. Everyone's scammed each other.
It baffles me to this date. We'll have to talk to you later. I have to go now.
And that's a, the conversation. I mean, that's, that's pretty much it.
Interesting stuff.
I mean, I don't know what you guys think of that.
How much does the government shape the scamming culture?
Very interested to hear what you think my guess is this will be a polarizing
interview and let me know what you think of the comments below.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].